good morning how many of you are lazy
this morning alright that's good I'm in
the right group excellent well I want to
talk about getting lazy my name is
Venkat Subramanyam thanks for coming we
when we hear about come from programming
we often hear people talk about
immutability for example and various
other things I won't even mention but I
find that a lot of those things are
really means to the end what we really
are after is efficiency and coding
well of course expressiveness of code is
also very important in function
programming uses that once we get
familiar with function style programming
but one of the real big benefits I think
really is lazy evaluation so that's what
I want to focus on today talk about how
we can actually what is lazy evaluation
and how we can actually benefit from
that I'll give examples from a few
different languages here I'll give a few
examples in Java a few examples in
c-sharp a little bit touch on Scala and
just a little bit on Haskell as well so
those are the four languages of touch on
to various degrees depending on what we
want to do best time to ask questions or
make comments is when you have it so
please don't wait till the end or
hesitate any time is a great time
questions comments anything you want to
talk about drawing attention I'll be
more than happy to listen to you as
you've noticed already I don't use
slides I hate using slides I'm going to
just rant off you know answer questions
if you have any writing code and just
have some fun so let's get started so
what does it really mean to be lazy what
does lazy valuation really mean well
lazy evaluation simply the first from
the so called eager valuation so
normally when a computation comes across
system can decide to do it right away
which is eager valuation or it can
decide to postpone it well benefit of
postponing it is we could do four things
with a postponed operation first when
you give me a computation I can do it
right away which is eager of course or I
can delay it to the point where I don't
have to run it at all and of course both
in life and computing efficiency comes
from not doing stuff that we don't have
to do so we postpone it until the point
where we maybe don't have to evaluate
this and we can just simply not evaluate
an operation or we can pass an operation
along to yet another entity which can
decide to do whatever
wants to do with it but of course we
could then eventually evaluate it but
minimally to get the results we want and
not really execute it eagerly to the
fullest extent well let's talk about
that a little bit further but I want to
talk about something else that we have
in computer programming but a lot of us
don't really experience it this is one
of the moments for me over the past
about thirty years I've been programming
and that is I used to read a lot about
stuff back in the 80s and I would like
to dare and say wow this is amazing
wish I could try this and it's it's it's
excitement really to me today is I can
actually try the stuff that I once were
only able to read because of the you
know so to say democratization of a
programming world we got a lot of things
available to us much more easily
available without having to really go to
a you know bigger corporation or a
university to get access to things we
can just have them available to us on
our own laptops and devices well one of
the things I want to talk about today is
applicative versus normal order well
most of us program in mainstream
languages which only support
unfortunately the so called applicative
order normal order is actually quite
abnormal in a lot of ways so let's talk
about that with a little example to see
what that really means in this context
so let's take a little example to play
with it so let's say we have a little
function here let's keep it extremely
simple
I got a function called a compute and
the function compute of course is going
to take a number and let's keep it
extremely simple returns as their double
of the number but of course within this
I'm going to simply say called so we can
actually see that this function actually
was called but of course I'm going to go
back here and say int let's say x equals
to 4 and then I say if X is greater than
5 and the compute of let's say 5 is
greater than 10 then I want to go ahead
and say for example in this case we'll
simply output here let's call this as a
result otherwise we'll say else really
silly but we'll call this as no result
so if you notice this we have a little
code where if X is greater than 5 then I
call compute and then of course I print
out result or I print out note
but when I round this code of course
everybody in this room knows that when I
run this code the compute method was
absolutely not called well why was
compute not called at all does anybody
know the reason for it come on don't be
shy
thank you very much John McCarthy
created this concept of charts of cuting
way long time ago in the 1950s and
everyone programming knows about shots
of killing in fact that's kind of normal
for us to expect executing there's no
surprise at all we program knowing short
screws securing very clearly on the
other hand if I say temp is greater than
10 and I'm going to say int the temp
equals compute well the question for you
now is will compute B called yeah we
said yes should compute be called no
right so this is when you are feelings
differ from what the language thinks it
should do when you disagree with the
language guess who wins the language of
course right which is a sad part but of
course in this case when you run the
code it is going to go ahead and call
the compute method there's no doubt
about it
and of course in this case the compute
of course is going to return the value
but sadly the compute was called even
though you and I know very clearly the
result of compute is not going to be
used an example of eager evaluation but
more so an applicative order but it
doesn't have to be this way it is just
this way in a lot of languages we use in
the mainstream but let's take this
example a little further just to play
with it now let's take an example here
in Haskell for a minute I'm going to
create a function over here called add a
and B equals a plus B and of course I'm
going to call a function call evaluate
let's say value equals value and then I
say main equals and I'm going to print
evaluate and then I'm going to call add
over here and one and two now when I run
this code of course what you can see is
it printed three that's not the most
interesting part in this code but let's
talk about the order of evaluation here
for a minute well in language like Java
and
c-sharp and a lot of mainstream
languages when will ad be called well ad
will be called right away when you see
the ad being Val you know called over
here the evaluation is instantaneous
it's eager it's also known as
applicative order so the word
applicative order is just the order in
which it is applied
well ad is applied then evaluate is
applied apply is a very fancy word for
invoke are called so when ad is called
it gets called are evaluated well but
has color is very different in that
regard in the terms of how it's going to
do this stuff so most languages we use
in mainstream use applicative order but
some languages actually use normal order
which is quite abnormal like I mentioned
let's go to this example I want to show
to you that ad is not being called right
away ad is actually pretty evaluated
pretty lazily so when you go to Haskell
and say hey call ad Haskell says why
because I want to pass it to evaluate so
you need to call evaluate too and it
says but why well I want to pass it to
print okay that's a good reason because
print is going to show the result humans
will see it I better do this work so
it's going to postpone until the point
when it cannot postpone anymore but how
do we prove it well unfortunately I
cannot put a print statement in language
like Haskell to prove it because print
statements are impure operations Haskell
wouldn't allow me to put it in arbitrary
places so scratching my head you know
how do we prove that this is how this
works and I never thought I would
actually use this debugger to make a
point but that's exactly what I'm going
to do here is to you know kind of step
through the code so I'm going to go here
and call G head C I which is the repple
are interpretive evaluator for Haskell
and I'm going to go ahead and load in
this case the sample dot HS file well
now that I've loaded it I'm going to put
a breakpoint but I'm going to put a
breakpoint right here on line number one
character number sixteen as it turns out
to be so I'm going to go back here and
say break at 1 and 16 so I've entered a
breakpoint now I'm going to go ahead and
call the main function well you can see
that the main has stopped right here on
line number 1 and it tells you that it's
waiting for you to continue
and of course they continue right now
and you can see the result of three
well that proved the point that ad was
actually called which is kind of
pointless because of course we know the
ad was called but what's really exciting
is I'm going to go back to this code and
change it to 42 now take a look at what
this code is doing when I run the code
of course the result was 42 but the
beauty is you could have currently
Haskell call the add function and have
the face but why because I want to pass
it to evaluate why are you calling
evaluate because I want to send it to
print well gosh then let's go ahead and
call evaluate first you come in to
evaluate you return to 42 you never
actually use value then Oracle says yeah
why bother then I'm not going to really
spend my effort running the add method
or add function because there is no
value in running it well is that really
true well to prove the point again I'm
going to go back to the rectal I'm going
to load up the function one more time
the file so it's loaded up I put a
breakpoint again
exactly in the same line of code as we
did a minute ago I'm going to go ahead
and call the main function this time but
notice it never hit the breakpoint it
actually went right through and printed
42 a proof that ad was never actually
evaluated well that's normal order right
there as we saw
so essentially Haskell says I don't have
to be evaluating stuff unless otherwise
I really need an evaluation this is a
very normal sequence in language like
Haskell but the first question of course
obviously is why can't other languages
like Java and c-sharp do this why does
Haskell do this differently and the
reason is actually extremely simple and
the reason is in Haskell almost
everything we create is pure so when we
talk about immutability and purity and
functional languages it's important for
us to understand why purity is so
important because if we don't understand
that to me purity are immutability is
like vegetables you don't go to children
and say you have to eat vegetables
nobody likes that so we got to give a
good reason why this is important
there's got to be a motivation to do it
and the
motivation as if a language does not
guarantee purity of a function well it's
got them eagerly evaluated languages
like this is really funny when you
really look at languages think about the
false language like C sharp and Java
fall on unsaved befalls languages like
Haskell fall on save default by
definition the default in languages like
Java and c-sharp is mutability whereas
by definition the default in language
like Haskell is immutability so when you
define a function in Haskell it is pure
by definition and if you want it to be
impure you have to plead with the
language you got to say please please
just as one function give me permission
to make it impure
whereas in language like Java and
c-sharp you have to plead with the
language to for purity because by
default those languages promote
immutability well because things are
immutable if something is not being
called when function can have side
effects if the function is not called
you're gonna get really surprised in
languages in fact you may ask the
question wait a minute if there is
really true why doesn't see sharp and
Java call the function when it starts of
cuted but why do they call it when I
sign to a temporary variable and the
short answer to that question is
language specs and language specs rule
so in fact if you read the language spec
for example C++ the language spec
actually clearly says even if you are
constructor word to perform a
side-effect the language compiler may
opt not to call your constructor so same
way language specifications clearly say
even if a function were to have a
side-effect a shot securing will reject
a function call and may not perform it
but language specifications do not apply
that rule in various other cases and
that's the reason why the languages
don't optimize so easily but let's take
that a little further and see how this
could actually be benefited with a few
exceptions if you will
understand that let's take this example
we just saw here of the compute method
but I'm going to write this example
again here but in the case in Scala for
a minute so I'm going to say over here
define compute and in this case of
course I'm going to say number given a
number which is let's call this as
integer if you will and then I'm going
to simply say go ahead and say I print
out let's say called and then of course
return number times two just like I what
I did in Java but in this case of course
I'm going to say X equals four if X is
greater than let's say five and compute
off let's say five is greater than ten I
want to print out let's say in this case
a result and then of course print out
else will simply say no result just
example what I did in Java I'm just
repeating that here in Scala well as you
can see in this little example you saw
the no result clearly compute was not
actually called but what if I take this
compute right here and assign it to a
variable called attempt over here and
then assign it to compute and then of
course run the code well when I run this
code of course what you see is
unfortunately Scala called computer as
well why because language like Scala and
f-sharp are what I call as hybrid
languages they promote immutability but
they don't guarantee immutability at the
language level so as a result they still
have to evaluate things well how do we
really get around that well Scala says
you know you could have a side effect in
compute I don't have a way to guarantee
that and if I don't call it you're going
to be surprised about it well you can
have a little discussion with the
language and say hey language compiler I
know what I'm doing here so give me a
little break here well that break comes
from the word lazy if you will so I
notice right now when I run the code
Scala did not evaluate the compute
method because I annotated the variable
with the word lazy this is very similar
to what you can do in F sharp as well
you can give a little annotation to the
language to say this one you can be lazy
about it and even if it were to have a
side-effect I'm not going to
offended if you don't call it so the
language says alright alright I leaves
upon the eager eagerness I overhear and
I'll postpone devaluation uncurl I
cannot avoid the call do it but of
course in this case as you can see if X
we're greater than two and I run the
code you can see that it actually called
it because in this case the value of
stamp is needed but if the value is
let's say greater than five in this case
you can see it bypass the call well that
brings up the question gosh how do I do
this in languages like Java and c-sharp
short answer in Java
good luck there is no way to do this
well c-sharp makes it a little bit
easier if you want to do something like
that I'm going to just grab this
function here from Java if you don't
mind and bring it over here to C sharp
so right here is the compute method and
you know how to go from Java to c-sharp
right just convert methods to uppercase
you got almost the code you want well so
here I have a code here in c-sharp the
compute method takes a number and
returns a double of that and of course
in this case I want to print that out so
we'll simply say here's the
console.writeline I'm going to simply
say call right here but I come back here
and say int the temp is equal to four
actually X equal to four and I'm going
to say if X is greater than 5 and
compute and I'm going to say this
compute method takes a value let's say 5
is greater than 10 let's say and again I
want to say result and of course else I
want to simply say in this case no
result well what does c-sharp do well
clearly in this case you can see it said
no result
then he only called the method short
securing at work but what if I were to
take this one again but this time I'm
going to say temp over here and I say
temp is equal to compute 5 and you can
see that C sharp is being eager just
like Scala and Java were but in the case
of c-sharp what you could do is again
annotated by saying lazy in for example
and you can of course define it as lazy
but that brings up the question how do I
really make things lazy in languages
like Java and c-sharp well this is where
a little bit of a charm comes in I'm not
completed with the c-sharp code yet but
I need one more minute before I can do
that so
come back to that so some languages are
born lazy they were bought at the beach
they were sitting there and doing
absolutely nothing useful when they were
born right so some languages are born
lazy from the get-go but some languages
have to work really hard to be lazy some
languages are like me
I'm always hyperactive trying to do
stuff and my wife would tell me some
days why don't you just sit down and
relax
I'm like how do you do that well that's
the way some languages are they're just
eager and you got to work a little extra
hard if you want to make them lazy lazy
so we talked about the ego versus lazy
but how do you really bring lazy
evaluation to some of these languages
how do you postpone these evaluations
well this is where the charm of lambda
expressions come in so what do land
expressions do well lambda expressions
really are anonymous functions so you
can create a function but one of the
really nice things about creating
functions as lambdas is you can pass
functions around so a function can now
receive other functions you can create
functions within functions as lambdas
and you can also return functions or
lambdas from other functions to we of
course call them as higher-order
functions so what does this give us a
benefit with the benefit you get out of
this is now you can pass functions
around but what's the benefit of passing
functions around imagine I have a
function I want to say here is a
function I'm going to give it to you
well what would you do when you receive
something on your hand there are three
things you could do you could use it
right away if I were to give you an
apple for example you were you could eat
the Apple right away or you can't
postpone be lazy about it and you can
eat the apple later on you could throw
it in your trash can and say I don't
want to eat this half Apple all you
could give it to somebody else and say
here you go I got this Apple but I want
to give it to you and that person in
turn can do one of those four things
give it to somebody else
eat it discard it or you know eat it
later so the point really is when we
pass functions around we can either be
lazy or eager or evaluated right now are
discarded and so this gives an
opportunity for us and that's exactly
what languages like C sharp do so notice
what I'm going to do here
I'm going to send a new and I'm going to
create a lazy over here so this becomes
a lazy off end but I'm going to wrap
this into a little lambda expression if
you will and of course in this case you
can see that I've just done a little bit
of postponing in here and of course in
this case I say temp dot value is
greater than 10 and I'm going to
evaluate it but notice the laziness in
this case c-sharp did not evaluate the
compute function why because a
computer's wrapped into a lambda and the
lambda doesn't have to be evaluated
right away the lazy object says now
thanks for giving this to me but I will
wait until I see what happens now of
course in this case if I say X is
greater than 2 and run the code you can
see that it did call it because the
value was after all needed but when did
this evaluation actually happen well to
prove that if I say here over here you
can see that here was actually called
and then much later was the call the
function evaluated that is the laziness
of the evaluation as you can see so in
other words we can use laziness to
really make advantage of this if you're
programming in Java
unfortunately lazy is not available but
nothing stops from creating one yourself
if you want to and you would use a
supplier to do this in language like
Java the code at highlighted here in
c-sharp is equal into what's called a
supplier in Java and you can get to get
get to use that pretty much to implement
the same idea if you are interested in
doing so we can see how laziness comes
into picture right there but I want to
take this further and say what can we
benefit from when it comes to lazy
evaluation and to understand that I want
to take yet another example and play
with it I'm going to use this example in
Java but you could use that in any other
language but a quick show of lands I
could use either one how many of you
program in Java here a few hands
something a few in c-sharp I'm sorry
well you know who wins here ok so we'll
just use the c-sharp example in that
case so I'm going to use I'll come back
and show you another example of Java
later later on but for now we'll use a
c-sharp example so to prove a point here
I want to
this little example and I want to say in
this case well what do we want to do
let's say we start with a list of
numbers to begin with so I'm going to
say int over here we'll call it numbers
equals and in this case I'll say new
list of int again well in this case
let's define a few numbers let's say 1 2
3 but notice I put a 5 and then a 4
change the order here intentionally and
then I'm going to say 6 7 8 and this
potentially could go on to a million
values let's say it doesn't really
matter but I want to say find the double
of the first number greater than 3 and
is even well I want to perform this
operation so how would I do this in a
language which is imperative in nature
let's start with a little example I'm
going to say result is equal to 0 to
begin with I want to print the result
you can pretty much do this example in
Java much like what I show you here not
very different at all so you can try it
out in either of those languages so in
this case of course I'm going to say far
well for each of course I'm going to say
bar and I'm going to say element and
coming from in numbers and of course I
want to loop through these numbers and
get the result out of it but how do I
get the result I'm going to say e is
greater than 3 and E mar 2 is equal to 0
well then what do I do I'm going to say
result is equal to element times 2 and
do a break operation out of it
well we all know what this style of
programming is it's an imperative style
of programming but imperative style of
programming involves mutability often it
also is very verbose it's something we
have done up for a long time but it's
tedious and it's a lot of work for us to
do I'm going to also say that infrared
Acela programming often has accidental
complexity dig into it it's often
error-prone as well I could do this a
lot better in functional style of
programming let's see how we can do that
here in c-sharp so what I'm going to do
in this example is repeat this but this
time I'm going to say well numbers start
and I'm going to say we're given a
and I want to say he is greater than
three and of course I could have really
said he is greater than three I could
have done that here but I'm going to
instead call is greater than three as a
function then I'm going to say where and
I'm going to say is even a second
function I want to call then I'm going
to say a select and I'll call it as
double it and then finally in this case
I will simply say Oh what do I want to
do the first number of course I'll call
first right here and as for the result
out of it well of course I need these
little functions to make this work so
let's get that going so public static
boolean is greater than three well that
should be fairly easy to do what does
that do well takes a number but of
course and all I'm going to do here is
simply say return number is greater than
three well let's go ahead and quickly
write those other two functions I would
need this of course is easy even and all
that it is doing is mark two is equal to
zero and finally this is going to become
a double it and all that the double it
function does is simply return back
let's say number times two and returns
the double of that particular number
well when we run the little code you can
see the result of that is also eight so
that's a functional style code now
clearly some of the benefits you see up
here if you take this code and ask
somebody what this code is doing what
are they going to do they're going to
have to look up and down in fact this is
a beauty put us on you know imperative
style code in front of somebody but then
sit in front of them and watch their
eyeball movement it does this right and
it goes up and down up and down and then
it does this that point is called the
point of confusion because I like what
does this code really do right now well
the beauty of the code in the bottom is
it's a single pass through the code
given all the numbers that I have been
given to me get me only the numbers
greater than three now get me only their
even numbers double them get the first
one what a relief
isn't it it's a single pass through you
go from the top to the bottom the code
begins to read like a problem statement
our
working with the company in the in the
not part of the US and I don't know
anything about what they do I was there
to just do what training course I was
offering but one of the developers said
would you please take a look at my code
and comment about it usually I get
scared when people do that because when
I can understand most of their code if
it's not written very well but I look at
the code and immediately was a release
because well I could actually understand
this code because the code was pretty
much doing what you see up here it's got
ships coming in it says what all the
ships are we are dealing with we want
only ships that are arriving and one
from the international destination and
one with this kind of cargo and I'm like
going through the stop down and I'm
reading through the code and I'm
understanding it I'm like wow even I
could understand your code what's up
with this right and that's one of the
benefits is that the code is actually
easy to read easy to Express but that
makes the question oh my gosh what about
performance well be careful about this
though if you're programming in language
like Ruby are you know other languages
this might not give you a good
performance if you're not very careful
about it but languages like C sharp and
Java have done a really wonderful job
this is why I really appreciate these
languages they didn't just bring in the
concept and say good luck with it they
actually took the time to do a really
good job with it let's see what that is
in a second let's go back to this code
here but I want to remind you about the
sequence we are working with one two
three five four so what is the number of
effort units of work we do in the
imperative code well let's take a look I
got this collection on my hand he is one
to begin with well one is greater than
three no one two is greater than three
no three is greater than three no five
is greater than three yes of course
he is five even well no is 4 greater
than three yes is four even yes double
four while that was eight computations
we performed so the total cost of this
was eight units of work that's what we
did so eight units of work in the
imperative code not all units the same
but that's good enough for our purposes
here
so in the imperative style we did
eight units of work let's look at this
cord naively for a minute
give it a collection of ten numbers I
had to ask if every given number is
greater than three
that's what ten operations
dead-on-arrival because ten already is
greater than eight but to add add insult
to injury then we take seven values and
see if they are even ten plus seven
seventeen computations then we double
three of the values seventeen plus three
four values of the one error well that's
twenty-one computations while 21 units
of work so this looks like 21 units of
work compared to let's say 8 units of
work but if you really wanted to make
this worse just add a few more values to
the end over here while the imprint of
style code is sitting there and saying
aha no worries your functional code is
going to do a lot more work that doesn't
look really that appealing isn't it well
here comes the good news I forgot to
mention one little thing about these
kinds of functions and I've only seen
these capability among my own children
and functional style code they both are
lazy to the bone in fact I'll give you a
little scenario I've seen at my home a
lot because that really doesn't it swell
witness my wonderful wife often have to
talk to my children while I'm away and I
got teenagers well if you have teenagers
you know what I'm talking about or if
you have been a teenager once you
wouldn't know what I'm talking about
well teenagers are fundamentally lazy as
you know so my wonderful wife will tell
my teenage son hey turn off the TV it's
like no words were spoken because
nothing happens in the house and she
clown looks at him it's like well I told
him to turn on the TV nothing happened
then she says go put the trash out and
no muscle was actually moved then she
says do your homework nothing really
happened then she says I'm calling daddy
and everything works well they could
have renamed the first as called daddy
that would have worked really well in my
opinion or call mommy in
families depend on the house but the
point really is these are what are
called terminal operations in other
words when you go to the list and say
where it says yeah okay thank you for
asking me to do that but maybe I'll do
it maybe I won't do it
where again and let's select maybe first
oh dear let me get to work because the
resort is needed after all well let's
see actually see if that's true sort of
prove that I'm going to go back to this
code right here and I'm going to go
ahead and say outboard and I'm going to
say e is greater than a GP called for
width and let's go ahead and say zero
here and then let's put number similarly
I'm going to go ahead and output let's
put YZ even right here and then of
course finally you will call this as
double it now before they run this code
let's go back and see how this is going
to be evaluated well this function does
not let me tell you what it doesn't do
it does not evaluate that particular
function e is greater than three for all
the elements in the list instead what it
actually does is it takes three three
and that's what's called C using it just
pushes them together into one function
if you will because it's all lazy
functions and puts it together and says
here we go and it runs that fuse to
function for element but only to the
extent how much it's needed so in other
words it takes one and says hey 1 are
you greater than 3 and 1 says oops not
and it bails out gets out of there
so does 2 & 3 well then comes along 5
and 5 says of course I'm greater than 3
but 5 escapes at this particular point 4
comes along 4 0 & 3 4 is even we double
the four and first says Oh tanks and
entire mechanism says oh we're done then
no need to touch 6 and values after that
and so when I run this code you can see
the output exactly eight units of work
one more time we evaluated 1 2 3 5 & 4
but we never ever touch 2 6 after all
because that is lazy evaluation at work
so lazy evaluation gives efficiency and
code so even though this cord looked
really expressive and beautiful we have
often concern about performance but be
rest assured with lazy evaluation we
don't have to worry about it because it
doesn't do the work until it no longer
can avoid doing the work just because we
have a functional style of code don't
assume that this is available not all
languages are created equal
this is an example in c-sharp so is an
example in Java if I create a very
similar example you will see Java doing
the same thing both Java and c-sharp
also have embraced this efficiency you
can again see the specification of being
different here even if these functions
were to have side-effect they may not be
called after all well that brings up the
point if you're interested in using
functional style it's important for us
to avoid side effects in our code in
other words make functions pure because
those functions may never get evaluated
and we should be very careful about
impurity of operations so all they'll
talk about immutability and impurity
have a really bigger end to it which is
lazy evaluation and efficiency that we
really are after so we can see the
benefit of laziness here in this code as
you can see and it decides not to
evaluate this function until it no
longer it can no longer can postpone it
that's one of the biggest benefits you
got out of it so that laziness gives us
a benefit of having to really postpone
operations if you will so as a result in
this case you don't have to worry about
running computations that don't have to
be run that is one of the biggest
benefits you get out of laziness lazy
valuations has the performance
implications but ok so we can have
laziness and code that's great but can
we benefit from laziness moving forward
to a bigger degree and once this this is
the beauty of things one thing leads to
the next thing and generally speaking
every single step may be really small
but the minute you have taken five or
six or seven steps and then you take a
few more steps
you certainly feel that you are
indifferent slower than you were in and
that's one of the biggest benefits is
you keep adding on to these benefits so
in the beginning we are saying Mitch
your functions are pure well make sure
you honor immutability mixture functions
are pure makes your functions don't have
side effect was what is the benefit that
gives you several benefits just one of
them being that you can have laziness
but now that we can have laziness what's
the benefit of that
well one benefit is of course efficiency
of code but there's yet another benefit
and that is you can start bringing in
evaluations which are you know related
to infinite streams what is an infinite
stream for this I'll give you an example
here in Java but you can write an
example in c-sharp
as well I'll maybe convert this to
c-sharp and show you in just a few
minutes but what is what is infinite
streams well an infinite stream
absolutely has no bounds to it so I'm
going to say stream dot e to rate and
I'm going to say here is 1 comma given
an element element plus 1 what does this
do
well it says this is Java example as you
can see it says I'm going to start with
1 then I'm going to go to 2 3 4 5 and
keep on going well how long can the
stream go well there's absolutely no
limit it's infinite in size I know what
you're wondering you're saying if it's
infinite in size what in the world would
you store it on the cloud of course
you're just kidding
so the point really is it's infinite but
how could you potentially have an
infinite stream
the answer is laziness so this lambda
will not be evaluated until it really is
needed and that is the beauty of lazy
evaluation what laziness gives an
ability for us to have things like
infinite streams you can't tell it how
many elements you want and it'll
evaluated on demand when you actually
ask for it and if you don't ask for it
it's not going to do the work to get you
that well what's the benefit of using
something like this well let's go ahead
and take a look at how we could benefit
from this in terms of getting something
really powerful and easy to work with
well now you have
a initial value and you have a generator
that going to generate subsequent values
for you and we can leverage on this idea
really nicely well to understand this
let's take a little example let's say
given a number let's say N and the K
while given numbers let's say N and K
let's say compute the square root of the
let's say first K even numbers are
starting from let's say n what compute
the total of square root of K even
number starting from n well seems like a
very simple problem to do compute the
square root total of the square root of
first K even numbers starting from n so
let's go ahead and say compute and then
I'll say N and K well what in the world
is n let's give a random number 72 to
begin with and I want to give another
value for K which is another random
number 219 let's say well I want to
perform this operation and get the
result out of it so how would I go about
doing this work well I'm going to say in
this case compute let's say double and
we'll call compute n comma K and of
course these are going to be simple
values to pass in what what are we going
to do well let's say in index is equal
to n to begin with after all we need to
work with an index value don't we well
then I'm going to say count equal to 0
we are absolutely to count then I say
double result is equal to 0 and then
finally I'm going to return the result
when we are done what did we do so far
really no useful work after all
right we all we did was we define some
variables and it's a good time to take a
coffee break and there was a lot of hard
work right well the point is in
imperative style code we create a lot of
these things called garbage variables
garbage variables are variables simply
there to provide our code some some you
know points to store data but we know
they don't have a really good purpose at
all in the code then I'm going to say
wild count is less than K and what do
you normally do it's a ritual isn't it
you stop and
asked the question he said less than or
less than or equal to do you ever ask
this question every single day isn't it
in fact it's cold like this that makes
us feel really stupid right because you
look at that code and you say is it less
than or less than or equal to you're
trying really hard to reason it and then
you leave the computer and we stop by
the door what's real is van and you're
eating food at Lund dinner and the
family says are you ok yeah I'm fine
you look really pensive no I'm thinking
is it less than or less very equal to I
forgot at work right it's always this
thread that goes along you're not sure
ever right these are code that's really
hard to reason we have to think very
carefully to know what this code really
means then what do you do then you say
well if it's even after all so I'm going
to say if the index is mark two is equal
to zero
yeah we have a value that is even so
what do I do now I'm going to say over
here result plus equal to math dot
square root and then of course I'm going
to take the index value and compute the
math out of it are we done well you're
going to say no we're not done we need
to increment the index value well okay
so here is index plus plus are we done
oh no not really you gotta increment the
count value so count plus plus are we
done what do you think is it correct
no what's missing the plus plus has to
be outside okay let's move it outside
is it correct now you're like no no no
one of them has to be inside one has to
be outside well which one then well
index has to be outside but count has to
be inside is it correct now you're not
sure anymore right that's the beauty of
imperative style code you're never sure
about it you're sitting there and
picking deeply to reason it and then of
course you're like I think it is correct
right and you're trying to run through
that and see what the result is to see
what the performant what the code is
going to provide as a as a response well
of course in this case I'll mark it a
static function and
course it gave us some result but God
knows if it's correct well but how do we
do this code in more of a functional
style well thanks to lazy evaluation and
infinite stream let's see how this is
going to become a lot easier to work
with so I'm going to comment this code
out but we implement it in a functional
style so here we go so what are we going
to do return stream dot eat r8 and I'm
going to say iterate what am I going to
do starting with the number N and then K
while given an element element plus 1
there is your infinite stream that you
have with you now what does the stream
do I'm going to start with N and I'm
going to keep on going n plus 1 n plus 2
n plus 3 and it keeps going well what's
the next thing filter and what am I
going to do with this filter well given
an element I'm going to say element mark
2 is equal to 0 well give me only the
even numbers well ok great
what's my next operation map this value
give an element return math dot square
root of that value so we performed what
we did on line 18 and line number 19 we
took care of those two lines but then
how do we go how much do we go limit
toward K values is it less than K is it
less than or equal to K it's K damn it
keep moving you don't have to waste your
time on it right and that's the beauty
of this is simply you have this filter a
map and of course limit and what's the
last step we want to perform some
operation and of course in this case I'm
going to perform a sum and get the
result out of this particular function
so when I run this code of course it
says I want the stream so let's go ahead
and implement a stream right here
bringing the stream dot stream so now
that I have the stream on my hand
what am I going to do now well run the
code and you can see the difference not
only is the code concise the code is
extremely expressive as well as you can
see right here so what's the benefit the
benefit is you're not really dealing
with accidental complexity in the code
you're not sitting that in struggling
with garbage variables you're not
struggling with less than or less than
equal to you're not dealing with control
variables the court becomes extremely
simple to deal with if you have the code
in the top and you're looking at that
code struggling to understand what the
code is doing when a business analyst
comes to you and says hey what does this
go do your response normally is that's
what I'm trying to figure out you shut
up because you're really angry dealing
with the code whereas in the code in the
bottom well you can actually discuss
with somebody and say that's what the
code is doing does that really make
sense to you because the code begins to
resume of the problem statement but of
course in this case lazy valuation plays
a very vital role because without
laziness absolutely you cannot do this
so lazy evaluation is critical let's see
how we can do this of course in Java
well in c-sharp of course e sharp was
influenced greatly by link so the
functions don't look like filter and map
but there are very equal and functions
to do how would this look like in the
case of c-sharp well let's take a look
at that really quickly to see how we
would probably some implement something
like that potentially here so let's get
this back to rolling well of course I
want the map and the square root well
before I do that really quickly here you
could actually do a little bit of
simplification here in Java as well
using what I call the method references
and that can minimize a little bit of
noise in the code if you will just a few
little benefits similarly if you had
that other function available separately
you could just use a method reference
for it also well of course in this case
I want the series to begin with but
where in the world is the series I don't
have one yet so let's go ahead and
create it so public let's say in this
case static I'm going to say i
enumerable and then of course in this
case I'm going to create an enumerator
for the int itself and I'm going to call
this as series if you will and what if
the series do well I'm going to say
account is equal to n whatever that
value of n potentially could be so in
this case I'll say a number is n that I
want to start with then I could say wild
true and then I could say yield the
return and then in this case of course I
could return
count plus plus and I could start
returning a number in the series if you
will
starting with this particular number or
the value that I'm interested in
returning well then of course once I do
this I got a series on my hand I can
start with the series but then I can say
dark we're given a particular number I
want to say number mod 2 is equal to
zero and of course I'm accidentally to
extract only the even numbers I don't
care about anything else then I could do
a select given a number again I can say
math dot square root of that number and
I can return a square root of that
particular value and then finally of
course I can say take and then give the
value K that I'm interested in and of
course this will start with the value
and that we were supposed to start with
so n is equal to you know whatever the
value is my memory is so wonderfully
flawed as you can see here while the
value n is 72 over here so let's say 72
and then of course in K equals 219 that
I wanted to use so we could say those
are the values that I want to work with
a little different here in c-sharp then
we saw in Java but a series is creating
with a yield word and it says I'm going
to keep producing values along the way
when you ask if and when you ask it and
finally I perform at some operation on
the result and print it so what we can
do in this case of course is we could
print out the result in the very end ask
you to perform the computation so you
can see that is a fairly simple
equivalent of c-sharp code to do almost
exactly what we did in the Java side and
we got laziness in this case so what
we're doing here is the take operation
is kind of like the limit operation you
saw on the Java side the take says only
take K values out of this and not
anymore
well the evaluation of the innumerable
is lazy as you can see it only performs
on demand and it evaluates as many times
as you ask you to take the value and no
more so you can start benefiting from
code like this and you can have laziness
being you know come into picture so we
can see how lazy evaluations lead to
efficiency in code quite easily
well the point I want to really
summarize this width is that one of the
really big charming features in
functional programming if somebody comes
to you and says what's really cool about
functional programming or what would you
really tell them as what is charming
about function I'm sorry Oh obviously
programming so when somebody says what
is really big deal about object of
programming is I'm going to say other
from the programming is really all about
polymorphism so isn't that true because
what you really are after an Opie is
polymorphism because if you don't have
polymorphism because Palmas will gives
you extensibility of code you can call a
function but the actual function that
will evaluate is not known to you at
compile time at runtime it will decide
what the function is based on the
runtime type rather than compile time
type so the most charming feature of
programming is polymorphism
there are good number of object on the
programming languages that don't even
have interfaces that don't even have
inheritance but all of them have one
thing in common which is polymorphism
well what about encapsulation well
encapsulation is extremely important
what about abstraction oh my gosh that's
extremely important but they really are
after one thing encapsulation and
abstraction really provide polymorphism
to us with our encapsulation you cannot
attain polymorphism opie
so the real most charming feature of OB
for me is really polymorphism so I am
going to say a lazy evaluation so lazy
evaluation is to function programming as
polymorphism is to opie because that is
what we really are after what are we
really saying in functional programming
oh you better really honor immutability
you better write pure functions you
better really honor all these wonderful
things but often the question is why
because what we really are after is
efficiency that we get from a lazy
evaluation so to me the real charm in
programming is the efficiency we get
from things like lazy evaluation of
course parallelism is also possible and
makes it easy with the mutability but of
course things like you know parallelism
and lazy evaluations won't be possible
with our purity of functions but the
real purpose of purity of functions is
not because we want to be fancy about
keeping functions pure it's not a
fashionable thing the real reason why we
go after those things is it leads to a
greater good which is lazy valuations
and potentially parallelism where it
makes sense and that's what we really
are after so that's really the charm in
functional programming is efficiency
through lazy evaluation I hope you will
be eager to make use of laziness that's
all I have hope that was useful thank
you there is so the question and I'll
repeat the question so the question is
what about resources for you know in
c-sharp honestly I had a really hard
time getting my heads around functional
programming and I I really finally
decided to invest a lot of time in
learning Haskell and I failed three
times doing it and and then I realized
the reason I found it so hard to learn
Haskell was I was approaching it the
wrong way I was getting really a you
know wrapped around by and and and at
the test the the sorry the type
information and then I realized that
Haskell actually is so wonderfully
statically typed I don't have to really
spend my time stay saying the type
information so much but the point really
is learning Haskell actually made me a
lot better in writing functional code in
multiple languages c-sharp you know Java
and so on so the irony is I would say if
you really want to get better write it
you know take your time to learn Haskell
and and I go out to learn about
languages I would probably not even use
at work and the reason I do that is
because by learning those languages that
I wouldn't use I actually end up using
the languages I do have to use in a lot
better way than I do
so my recommendation actually is to go
learn Haskell and the reason I say that
is it takes you away from your comfort
zone
you're thinking about it in a completely
different way because you're away from
your comfort zone and then you end up
actually using some design you know
principles and patterns that you
normally wouldn't and then when you come
back to the language you are familiar
with now you're thinking about it very
differently then when we normally do in
the constraints of the language as we do
one of the biggest constraints I see
often programming your language is I am
constrained by what the language already
provides and there are things that I can
actually do in the language outside of
what it provides in a very tactful way
but I often don't even know that I could
do that because you know the language
has completely blinded me but when I go
use a language which is completely
different then I come and start
tinkering with the language and say well
I didn't realize I could actually do
this so that's what I would say is go
you know look at completely different
things and then maybe that was really
change the way you think about in
programming language other questions are
comments yes please start over the
question okay yeah okay so sometimes a
lazy evaluation can come also cause your
headaches and the if you're a c-sharp
programmer like resharper a few versions
back said hey change everything to
ienumerable and and then you know you
can pass more things see methods and
then and then immediately afterwards you
start getting all these warnings saying
whoa you may be in enumerated this
innumerable two times and whilst whilst
well you know we're dealing with things
that aren't coming from a database or
aren't coming from files you could but
all of a sudden you know when that when
enumerated that numerable is slow you've
now gotten got yourself another problem
right so so I that's a fair point
and one of the things I want to really
emphasize is it also tends out to be a
lot more than syntax when we get into a
language or a seasonal language the
first thing we come across is a syntax
right oh we're trying to understand all
these constructs and how to put them
together my argument is almost
invariably
we can have a really good command of the
semantics of the language because we
don't really take the time to understand
the semantics and the implications of a
particular thing we're working with a
construct in the language we could a get
infatuated with ideas which is not going
to help us or get drawn into certain
code not understanding the real
implications offset and then we end up
facing some of these challenges as well
and so you know in fact a lot of ways
it's no longer what you see is what you
get right it's a lot more than what you
see that you actually end up getting and
and clearly that's a departure from the
syntax because syntax often shows you
what you are seeing and what you're
getting
well semantics is often what you don't
see you know visibly in front of you and
I think your question really in jizan
hey take the time to really understand
the semantics because semantics actually
rules right syntax becomes your muscle
memory after a while you're not thinking
about the syntax
after a while because it becomes your
second nature to code with that syntax
the semantics is something you have to
specifically think about every single
time because that's not something that
you're going to see in front of you but
that has a very strong reference to what
you do so your point I would say yes
you're absolutely right it's important
to understand the semantics and then we
can then say you know here are tools I
have in front of me but the semantics
tells me I shouldn't use this tool at
this point maybe I should still go back
and program in that imperative style in
this case and that's the beauty in
language like Java and c-sharp you have
the control now to decide when to use
which and I'm not suggesting functional
is the right thing all the time or
imperative is the right thing all the
time I think we have to choose based on
our current specific needs and and in
for myself what I find out a lot of
times is I don't know how to do the in
functional style right now so I do this
in imperative but three weeks from now
somebody shows me a better way to do it
in functional style and it's often not
the way that I thought I should do in
the first place but quite different from
what I thought but the beauty is I can
come back and refactor the code at the
time to a bit much better style than I
did so I absolutely I don't want to let
go of the performance and efficiency and
I can
pick and choose what makes sense based
on you know what what what I have at
hand yeah one more probably question
before we wrap this up oh all right well
thanks for coming then appreciate it
thank you
[Applause]